oh you're re-recording yeah [ __ ] kids
hey guys I'm Ryan right I'm Dan cypher
we're gonna be watching the trailer
today for Lego Jurassic world the video
game gameplay trade pop excited you know
these Lego games have really like taken
the [ __ ] off haven't dude
ever since Batman like that Lego Star
Wars was like yeah I love it they are
fun games like the controls are very
similar every time but it's fun and
they're like very movie based it's
awesome the Indiana Jones one was cool
too like I do dig these games to see a
Jurassic world one that is cool and from
what I've heard about this it's gonna be
all for the movies
oh sweet yeah so it's like Jurassic Park
1 2 3 and the Jurassic world so I've
heard interesting because there's been a
lot of horrible Jurassic Park games in
the past it might be longer good woman
you needed like a 15-year hiatus have
you have you have you ever played the
super that's what I was thinking oh if
that one's so bad it's but it was hard
to it was just like there's no way you
could be no you get into the first
building and you get like attacked by
Raptor in that yeah it's hard it's a
hard game [ __ ] hard but the best one
was the lost world at Chuck E Cheese
with the arcade oh [ __ ] yes yeah
infinite bullets that's [ __ ] awesome
I always died at the same exact spot
armpits tired of it yeah you can only
squeeze something for so long you know I
mean kids
love it already to announce a new bike
oops
pretty graphic cipher
okay
terrified Lego k-member
did they actually use the talent for the
movie and I think that's an audio
oh my god I love it I love it it's like
it's like a good Jurassic Park Lego
spoof you know totally because I'm
watching this I'm like this is pretty
[ __ ] scary and then they'll do
something really communicated no yeah
it's like oh they're spoofing Jurassic
Park at the same time while honoring the
scary parts or even when the t-rex is
chasing after them I love the angles
that they're choosing like out of all
the [ __ ] like movies the Lego people
could do yeah we've like adjusted to
their comic-book stuff and then star
wars and everything oh that makes sense
yeah that makes sense but who would have
thought like Jurassic Park yeah
especially Jurassic park's a pretty
violent [ __ ] movie well it's a lot of
off-screen death but it's a lot of death
well at one point a guy gets just
[ __ ] eaten by a t-rex off a toilet
yeah because Sam Jackson's arm it just
appears on someone like it's just oh my
god that's rude like there's some pretty
violence and then it and then the guy
who's like clever girl gets his face
just demolished there's some really
violent stuff in that movie and it's
terrifying I think it's really cool how
they're bringing it to life in a version
that like families can watch like that's
pretty cool it looks like a lot of fun
if you think about the demographic I
mean sure like kids play with Legos now
and the matter-of-fact like when I have
a kid like that's like the only toy kids
yeah good Legos but when we were kids
yeah Lego was like the fit yeah up with
like the beginning of Lego so yeah
there's still like a large demographic
that's just kind of like [ __ ] love
Legos and then it's like I love Jurassic
Park and they've been dressed apart Lego
so like it's that's cool like these
ladies are [ __ ] awesome I love it the
lego movie the lego movie was so best
animation movie I mean the longest time
that's not [ __ ] snow God everything
is awesome but the Oscars anyway guys if
you like more jokes like that and if
you're new you should subscribe to the
real region this is right here dan has a
gaming channel it's right here
plays games on the gaming channel
it's a lot of fun sometimes I go on
there very rarely though and you can
follow us on Facebook Instagram Twitter
drooly diets hello it's a female let's
see what you look like
always got to prove the looks of the
females always got to make sure yeah
she's pretty she is pretty good job oh
you are a successful subscriber no no
she's really cute I hope you're not
under 18 or else this is awkward
but yeah I'm gonna show everyone what
you look like because you are not gonna
sue me for saying how good-looking yeah
you probably will oh that's a boy just
don't sue me oh she's with a boy there
[ __ ] won't show him but what'd she say
this channel always makes me smile I
just wanted to say drew that we're glad
we can make someone so beautiful outside
and inside laugh it's truly a treasure
there's two gifts to the world
children's laughter and hot people hot
people yeah
and they go hand in hand you get with
the hot people then you have a children
and you make the chill relax oh my god
and then the cycle repeats oh my god
like you actually like a little bit
bloom I think I'm impressed
think I'm I'm very impressed you get
more than just laughs on the real
rejects you get an education and a
lesson in life so Giroux stay hot and
have a kid before you're 30 because
that's when women are old guess so